[Music]
[Applause]
Brian windhorst very busy ESPN senior
NBA writer before I get to the topics of
today can you give the audience a little
bit of the back story you went to the
same high school as LeBron and then
started covering them eventually
when he made the decision
did that that affected your life as as
well in covering LeBron that day
yeah I mean uh ESPN eventually hired me
and I moved to Miami
um but it was you know ESPN and I had
talked before and we thought there was a
chance he was going to go to Chicago or
New York you know if he left Cleveland
and they had operations in Chicago and
New York already and when uh he went to
Miami uh crickets
crickets absolute crickets
um and so a couple of months passed and
I was actually in Thailand on vacation
when I got a call from ESPN uh hey what
you want to do Miami
um so yeah that's how that went okay but
then you have to say to your wife we're
moving to Miami
my wife was in law school at Ohio State
so I mean we were we were engaged so it
was no it was not exactly a clean a
clean situation but um uh I I haven't it
was it was a tough for a few months but
I have I haven't regretted it but if I
were to ask you 30 minutes before the
decision where you thought LeBron was
going to go
what would you have thought well I I
knew it was Miami I actually think that
it was a stunner to me that the
Cleveland was that shocked I guess
social media wasn't which wasn't as a
thing as much in 2010 because there was
multiple reports that he was going to
Miami during that day I wrote a story
that was on Cleveland Plain Dealer's
website that basically said this I
couldn't independently confirm it but I
was you know it was it was out there
obviously you could have had a last
minute change of heart I would not have
ruled that out I don't know if LeBron
would have rolled it out
um but uh you know I was kind of
surprised at how amazed the Cleveland
was because obviously they were hanging
on every piece of information here we
had all this information and and um you
know yeah so the the the world didn't
know I think today there's no way that
could have been kept secret is the way
it uh it ended up doing so back in 2010.
I remember Jared Dudley for some reason
came out and said that LeBron was going
to the Knicks and and you know he's at
the boys and girls Club in Greenwich and
we thought okay he's going to the Knicks
was that ever a possibility for LeBron
the only Clarity that I had from
LeBron's camp that week was that it was
not going to be the next and I said as
much and uh was you know totally you
know did radio in New York and they told
me I was absolutely out of my mind that
him doing it in Greenwich guaranteed it
and I was like okay and actually Dan
Stephen A Smith he he had it like he was
a few days early and he called it I
think shortly after Bosh and Wade kind
of made a co-announcement which that
doesn't get remembered you know how
Boston Wade announced they were going to
play for the heat I mean Wade was
already but to resign Michael wilbon did
a 45 second to minute interview on the
noon Sports Center on like uh Wednesday
afternoon Boston way we're sitting
together they threw to wilbon he did it
it was wrapped in two and a half minutes
back to baseball highlights
um and then LeBron had his own show you
know maybe three four days later
Brian windhorst ESPN senior NBA writer
I'm wondering is the Joker joking with
us like he's got a unique sense of humor
you know the parade he doesn't want to
go to the parade he forgot the MVP
trophy and
I wonder if is he joking is he fooling
us with this personality here
well look I believe that he may not care
about the accruech for months like he
may not care about the physical Hardware
but I don't believe he doesn't care uh
this concept that this is just something
I do from nine to five or whatever the
shift is and then he's just like I gotta
get back to my family I don't believe
that I don't believe somebody becomes
that skilled in that and that amazing at
their craft uh who studies and is so
mentally prepared who doesn't care and I
do believe he cares about the MVP he may
not care about it like other people do
and he may not speak about it and I do
believe he cares about winning and
excuse me did you see him screaming on
the bench in the fourth quarter uh you
think that's a man who doesn't care I
mean he absolutely cares he just shows
it in a different way and he has his
priorities in a bit of a different order
um I do believe however uh that he would
prefer to be in Serbia uh because I'm
sure the parade it was it was everything
in Denver was totally cool I mean there
was unfortunately a shooting but
generally it was it was okay after the
um after the they wanted title the other
night it was a pain in the butt to get
out of Central Denver though and I
wouldn't I am very glad I am not having
to be a part of that parade today so I
get jokes not wanting to do the parade
there's Wishful reporting in all sports
that we hope that there's something
because that gives us something to talk
about so it could be Zion moving on or
they move on from him it could be Dame
in Portland it could be Bradley be on
Washington if you were going to rank
those three not Wishful reporting but
actual reporting the likelihood that who
was moved where would you start
I think the most likely of those is BL
to get traded
um the Wizards may not termit a rebuild
but
um they can't bring the same team back
they had like the ninth highest payroll
this year and didn't even make the play
in uh not acceptable this you don't need
like incredible Insider analysis to know
that they don't want to bring that team
back and the contract for Beale is
onerous you have to separate build a
player and build the contract because
right now we're talking about as a
contract they I think the Wizards want
out of that contract uh Michael Winger
who just got hired didn't sign it
um then I think uh Zion
um although I'm not convinced it's going
to happen because his value it's not a
good time to trade him his value was low
I just think that they've reached a
point there in in New Orleans where they
are now saying well what are our options
um and it's gotten I'm kind of surprised
at how out there is Dan like I'm being
very careful in how I'm couching what
I'm saying because I'm very sensitive to
aggregation and the last thing that I
want is report colon when Hurst says
Pelicans to trade Zion
I don't believe that but that said
over the last three or four days as I
talk to more and more teams I continue
to hear more conversations that the
Pelicans are having about it so
you can try to infer that I think that
there's a significant interest in them
in judging the market and then Lillard
as of right now and I have to underscore
right now it's 11 30 Eastern on Thursday
June 15th
as of right now
I think he wants to be a Blazer I think
the Blazers are trying to make moves to
to support him the trades that I have
heard the Blazers the negotiations for
the last few days are trades that are
centered around building around Dame
if they don't make a deal if they end up
drafting uh you know a teenager with the
the third pick next week I do think Dane
could reevaluate and say what are we
doing here
um but you're asking me right now at 11
right now Dame is is not being traded
nor is he asking to be traded
yeah he gets older they get younger
that's not a recipe for winning anything
in Portland uh well to be honest with
you
don't tell anybody this but the Blazers
kind of already started to rebuild
uh they tanked the last two years but
why not just continue then Brian see
this is this is the thing like if you
honestly
if they were hiring me as a consultant
I would say you had the number eight
pick last year they drafted Shaden sharp
who's got a high upside they have the
number three pick this year you're
already halfway there sure
you could you could see what the market
could get you for Dane but I also don't
have to fill the Moda Center
I don't I don't have to sit there in
front of the fans
um they have not been competitive within
the last couple of years as good as he
is so I would say I if I were them I
would seriously consider
saying we've already kind of started the
rebuild and what can we get for Dame
right now my God the the offers would be
robust but that is not how they are
acting that is not what Joe Crone and
the general manager has said that is not
how they are acting they are behaving as
if they are trying to build right now
around a guy who's been the best player
in franchise history and I I understand
that as well
you know Bradley Beal doesn't move the
needle he's a good player uh you know
you get get you 23 24 points but
nobody's showing up to go boy I gotta go
see Bradley Beal play
if you're the Miami Heat or whoever it
might be and they you know say all right
I'm bringing in Bradley Beal at 47
million dollars
and he's not somebody who I mean he
might make you better but he's not
making you more interesting
um it what's the market it feels like
there's a lot of teams that could be
interested in Bradley Beal help me
understand why you know a guy at age 30.
yeah so this is the thing
there's nobody ever going to say
anything bad about him they like him as
a player
the Wizards he's played 90 games the
last two years combined
um
he's got a no trade clause
the Wizards are not in position to
contend this year
if the Wizards keep him
and he has another injury played here or
he doesn't as another all non-all-star
season
they're in they're in a rough position
Dan
and in all honesty
the Wizards getting out of that contract
is potentially the asset that they get
in trading for Bradley Beal and I and I
have to underscore this please listen
aggregators
it's not that they don't like Bradley
Beal the person or the player it's the
contract the contract is the problem
in combination with the new rules that
are coming into the NBA which is if you
hit this what they call the second apron
you might as well be in leg irons and
shackles to improve your team they are
the owners are forcing parity down the
throat of the league and they are saying
you are not going to have
a high dollar third best player anymore
no LA Clippers no uh new Brooklyn Nets
no Golden State Warriors you're not
going to have payrolls that are 100
million dollars more than the rest of us
they can spend that much money but they
have made it impossible really to do it
for more than a year and so going
forward teams are going to be extremely
careful about what they pay like their
guys who are not their Uber Stars so for
example the Denver Nuggets have two Max
they have three max players
jokic is worth he's a bargain of twice
the price Murray absolutely Murray is is
going to get extended if he wants to
this summer
Michael Porter
I think in a couple years you will not
be able to have Michael Porter and I
don't just mean the Nuggets I mean any
team you will not be able to have a
third player who is on a Max salary who
is basically that type of player and the
problem is
um Bradley Beal
maybe maybe today he's a number two but
what about in two years maybe then he's
a number three and he's going to be
making 50 million dollars
with a no trade clause
so that is what the issue is here when
it comes to Bill it's that contract
combined with the new rules and in the
fairness of the Wizards when they signed
him to this deal last year they didn't
know these new rules were coming in
uh and they have been throwing a
curveball here and it is taken Michael
Winger their new president like of if he
would come in and look at the lay of the
land of course he's like boy can we do
something here and they're going to say
everything wonderfully about Beale
publicly and they are going to mean it
but they have got to try to get out of
that contract and that is why if there's
a trade people are probably going to be
surprised at how low he goes for last
summer when we saw gobert and Donovan
Mitchell get traded they was like oh my
God because frankly Bill's resume is
better than those guys at the level or
better but when you see what bielgus
traded for versus when you switch you
see with those Legos get traded for
people are going to be stunned and it's
going to take a while for them to
understand why and they're going to say
well what's wrong with them but we don't
there's nothing it's not a commentary on
him as a player
John Morant when and how much
well I don't work in PR but today is the
Nuggets parade
and next week is NBA Draft week uh when
benyama will I think one Manama is going
to get eliminated tonight in the French
league playoffs and I suspect he will be
in on U.S soil uh by next week I don't
think Adam Silver wants John Moran to be
the thing plus what day is tomorrow I
think it's Friday so that was my guess
that it would be tomorrow there's a
cushion before you get to the NBA draft
so and I'm just going to say I wish I
could tell you uh Dan oh yes my sources
have told me it is 36 games I don't know
what it's going to be I just don't know
I actually don't even have a feel I
don't even want to guess but I am going
to say that at the end of the regular
season the NBA gave out one of the most
severe suspensions they've given in Adam
Silver's tenure as commissioner to Miles
Bridges from the Charlotte Hornets who
pled no contest to a felony domestic
abuse charge he was given 30 games for
that uh for that plea I don't know if
it's I don't know the proper legal term
for that how would that legal thing
played out he admitted falter I don't
know I don't know how it works but 30
games so I know that there are people
who are who as soon as they heard what
Adam Silver said left to the conclusion
that oh my gosh it's going to be a year
it's going to be seven years they may
never let him into a game you know
um a couple of things here one
Adam the the standard is the standard
two this guy is extraordinarily valuable
to this league and they and the NBA want
this to be a bump in the road they want
jaw to be a superstar in this league for
a decade plus so they have got to make
sure that what they're doing here is
helping him take corrective action not
push him away and so uh no matter what
the suspension is I'm sure there will be
howls about it but this is a very
delicate situation with a player who's
extremely important both now into the
future
if I said you could have John Miranda or
Zion moving forward
well I'm worried about both of them
because they both play with kind of
Reckless abandon uh every time jaw jumps
I get worried because he has such
explosive athleticism I mean he is such
a joy to watch he plays like his hair is
on fire
I mean it's amazing to watch him play uh
if I was a young kid
just learning and watching the game
I would be so attracted to his style of
play and Zion Williamson is probably the
best in he and yokich are the two best
interior scorers since Shaq in Zion is
six inches shorter Zion is an absolute
offensive machine I have immense belief
in his talent but he lands like a ton of
bricks every time he jumps like it's
both of them job because he's seven feet
off the ground and and Zion because he
just lands like like a skyscraper
falling so I don't have all the data on
what it what their uh when they do those
tests on those machines and they see
their load I mean I'd be worried about
both of them but jaw has demonstrated
more health and um and you know I'm you
know and and you know frankly more uh
focus on the game so I would pick John
but I I'm worried about both of them
because they're both Dan they're both so
important to Future League take a look
at the guys who are under 25. if you if
you if you draw a line at 25 year olds
and down the NBA needs those guys really
really badly and um this is not it's not
a joke I know people make fun of Zion
and whatever this is real talk this is a
league that needs those guys to be great
and they are magnetic in both of their
ways they are magnetic and and so it's
definitely something to be worried about
uh final question uh if LeBron leaves to
play with his son someplace do you have
to move
no no I'm uh I'm done moving for LeBron
but uh
um I will say that uh
uh USC games uh are now going to be one
of the one of the uh the big draws uh
for this for this next season you got a
credential already for USC basketball I
have been to bronnie James basketball
games I will have to I have to cop to
that
great to talk to you Brian thank you we
appreciate your time that's Brian
windhorst ESPN senior NBA writer